squid game has been an absolute breakout
success and that's bad news for disney
the show is doing so well in fact that
even the head of netflix seems surprised
by it there's a show on netflix right
now that is the number one in the world
squid game is will definitely be our
biggest non-english language show in the
world for sure it's only been out for
nine days and it's a very good chance
it's going to be our biggest show ever
but there's actually a few really great
reasons why netflix's strategy here paid
off so huge they are basically doing the
exact opposite of disney when it comes
to creating new shows and people are
starting to pay attention even jeff
bezos had to pay his respects on twitter
to how brilliant this strategy was
calling it impressive and inspiring
naturally people were skeptical that he
would give netflix such a big compliment
since he did create amazon video after
all but bezos responded to those
comments directly saying that no it was
just simple admiration so why is jeff
bezos so excited about squid game even
though he hasn't even seen the show yet
well bezos is a businessman first and
foremost and he understands that squid
game is going to change everything for
the world of online streaming and the
business strategy is interesting but i
think the technological implications
here might be even bigger since squid
game could mark the key turning point
for the commercial use of deep fakes but
we'll get to that in a bit first we need
to cover why squid game is so successful
in the first place this isn't the first
time a foreign language show has broken
out and gone viral after all narcos
captured everyone's attention in 2015
with the wild story of pablo escobar and
the german time travel series dark was
wildly successful when it launched in
2017 but squid game is a little
different mostly because of the speed
with which it has gained popularity just
two weeks after launch squid game became
a massive phenomenon and topped the
charts in 90 different countries
including the united states the core
reason that squid game is so universally
popular and hard to put down is that the
subject matter is incredibly relatable
the main plot centers around a game show
with deadly consequences it's
essentially a last man standing
competition where whoever can stay alive
the longest wins millions of dollars
everyone has a relationship with money
and everyone fears death at some level
these themes cut across cultures and
allow anyone with a pulse to clearly
understand the stakes and get drawn into
the story but there's another reason why
i think squid game has been so
successful the subplot see while the
main plot centers around a group of
characters fighting for their lives and
millions of dollars the show introduces
a detective character who is trying to
uncover what's really going on mysteries
also make for incredibly engaging
stories so squid game is basically
putting one great story within another
great story if you went and deleted all
the scenes where the contestants were
playing the actual games and just
watched the detective work the case i
think you'd still be very entertained by
combining these two addictive genres the
creators of the show are basically
guaranteeing that you won't be able to
put it down and this strategy works
especially well because netflix releases
all of the episodes at once binge
watching is a critical part of the
netflix content strategy first and
foremost because it's just what viewers
want but there is a major drawback by
pumping out content all at once it's
much harder for netflix to drive
attention through positive reviews from
critics in fact netflix didn't even mail
out screeners of squid game to the press
before the show went live which is very
abnormal this could be because no one
not even netflix could have predicted
exactly how successful squid game was
going to be but it's also part of their
forward-looking strategy reviews from
established critics are increasingly
irrelevant just look at the consistent
disparity between dave chappelle's
critic scores and audience scores on
rotten tomatoes and netflix has the
power to design around bad critic scores
the netflix app could easily integrate
with rotten tomatoes or metacritic to
show users an aggregated rating before
recommending a movie or show but they
don't this is because netflix's
recommendations are driven by an
algorithm and only care about finding a
show that you the current viewer will
like clearly lots of people disagree
with critics and love shows that get bad
reviews and netflix is happy to serve
that content to the people who will
enjoy it when netflix releases nine
hours of content in one go reviewers
often can't even watch it all to write a
review before the show has gone viral
and that's a big advantage of the
bingeable release strategy the flip side
to all of this is the disney strategy
two years ago they launched disney plus
and the streaming service was an
overwhelming success the service broke
100 million users ahead of schedule and
now disney is doubling down and aiming
to release one new piece of content
every week there's a problem though even
though disney's content is on average
extremely high quality they don't have
very much of it this chart shows the
ratio of good shows to bad shows for
every major streaming service and disney
ranks incredibly well especially for
movies but when you look at the total
size of the disney plus content library
it's the smallest of any service this
makes sense though disney spends
billions of dollars developing major
franchises like marvel star wars and the
disney princesses they simply aren't in
the business of taking lots of risks on
smaller projects they would much rather
spend billions acquiring a company like
marvel that everyone already knows about
this leads them to miss out on wild
cards like squid game though the most
impressive thing about the squid game
virality is that it was based on no
existing intellectual property it wasn't
adapted from a book or a video game and
it still succeeded with no built-in fan
base now you could say that it builds
upon established works in the broader
battle royale genre especially movies
like as the gods will but there's
nothing stopping disney amazon prime or
apple from developing a similar title
they haven't though and the reason comes
back to the core netflix strategy
netflix focuses relentlessly on user
engagement the team there understands
that every night they are competing with
every other app to deliver something
interesting to watch that means having
lots of content instead of putting
massive resources into a single
franchise which people could get tired
of netflix focuses on taking risks on
lots of new projects many of them fail
but when one of them breaks out it
changes everything stock and netflix hit
all-time highs shortly after squid game
went viral so the strategy seems to be
working there is another netflix
competitor that we haven't talked about
yet though and they have way more
content than any other platform by far
i'm talking about youtube of course
which in some ways is the netflix model
on steroids there's now 500 hours of
content uploaded to youtube every minute
which now that i'm saying it out loud
makes me think that i'm kind of crazy
for trying to compete with all of that
but anyway great content clearly rises
to the top on youtube just like squid
game did on netflix and increasingly in
order to win in the content streaming
game you just need the most content this
all bodes well for netflix but we still
have to discuss internationalization and
the future of deep fakes netflix is by
far the most aggressive streaming
service when it comes to translation
they now offer subtitles in 37 different
languages and dubs in 34 different
languages this helps increase the reach
of every title in the netflix library
and no i'm not about to transition into
a vpn ad translation and dubbing are one
thing but they don't always work out as
planned i've seen tons of videos
floating around about how bad the
english dubs were for squid game and
yeah they're pretty bad but technology
is about to change all of that deep
fakes are already pretty impressive on
their own but they don't have a ton of
practical uses sure you can make a funny
video but they aren't widely used in
hollywood at least not yet part of the
problem with deep fakes is that in order
to get a really realistic result you
need an actor to stand in and give a
convincing performance they'll
definitely help movie studios bring back
actors to reprise famous roles long
after they're gone but that's a bit of a
niche use case deep fakes will also
probably help with future projects that
are like the irishman where older actors
are digitally de-aged to play their
younger selves within a story but i
still think that won't be as impactful
as what deep fakes could do for
internationalization two years ago a
team of machine learning researchers
released a paper called text-based
editing of talking head video in it they
describe a method for automatically
generating mouth movements to match
words that were never spoken by the
actor take a look at this sample i love
the smell of napalm in the morning i
love the smell of french toast in the
morning they also use this method to
create video of that guy speaking german
here we enable our non-german speaking
subject to speak german
even though this is just a demo and it's
two years old now the results are pretty
remarkable i really don't think it'll be
long until this technology is rolled out
at companies like netflix across the
entire content catalog there are still a
few major hurdles like dealing with odd
lighting scenarios and shots with heavy
visual effects but it definitely seems
within reach obviously you still need a
great voice actor to bring the
performance to life but ai is getting
better at generating realistic voices as
well so it's entirely possible that in a
few years translation dubbing and mouth
remapping will be fully automated deep
fakes are endlessly fascinating to me so
if you're working on anything related to
this i'd love to get in touch with you
to talk more about it in the meantime
please check out this recommended video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it
you